jean guy talamoni on va vous faire un
petit tard disions en ébauche parents
dans le qinghai
vous pensez à quoi là en ce moment je
suis en train de me demander quelle va
être votre question suivante quand avez
vous pleuré pour la dernière fois à
l'occasion d'un deuil
là bas vous avez l'occasion souvent oui
mais on leur aurait peut-être pas tous
les deux ils ne sont pas égaux dans la
vie d'un homme
que pourriez-vous dire de plus négatives
sur vous non je crois que peut dire que
je suis fainéant
c'est vrai j'aime pas tellement
travaillé ouais mais en revanche on peut
dire que je positive sur moi c'est que
je travaille quand même beaucoup dans
les régies du mérite parce que ceux qui
aiment travailler donc c'est plus facile
quand on est aussi le travail et vous
avez raison
kelly les insultes qui vous a fait le
plus mal je reçois temps en temps des
lettres d'insultés ça ça m'arrive
notamment l'assemblée de corse et
beaucoup beaucoup venant de la place
la quasi-totalité venant venant de
france met d'ailleurs je me suis aussi
beaucoup de lettres sympathique venant
de france alors au début ça mais ça me
faisait quelque chose et payeurs s'il y
avait un mot qui revenait à l'issue
d'une expression qui revenait souvent
ces [ __ ] de course et beaucoup
commençaient leur lettre d'un [ __ ] de
course
vous prenez les sous des français vous
voulez pas être français et cetera
vous êtes la danseuse de la france vous
[ __ ] salut de corps c'est quelque
chose
tout joueur est bon j'avoue que mélanger
fait plus tellement attention je vais au
panier
quelle est la question dont vous
aimeriez avoir la réponse j'aimerais
bien savoir non pas si la corse va être
indépendante mais quand elle va être
indépendante et quand elle va recouvrer
la maîtrise de son de son devenir
j'aimerais savoir quand parce que
j'aimerais bien le voir mais si je vois
pas ça fait rien vous avez préféré le
voir
vous avez menti pendant cette interview
non je n'ai pas menti et m'est arrivé de
mentir dans la vie quotidienne ça m'est
arrivé un jeu pas je suppose mais je
crois que en matière politique
le mensonge est dévastateur dévastateur
moi il m'arrive de pas répondre aux
questions notamment avec les
journalistes je le redis écoutez je vais
pas répondre par une moyenne calculée
santoni vous répondez par exemple la
junior là
vous avez là par contre non seulement je
n'y réponds pas mais j'aurais du mal à
vous répondre mais il ya des questions
que je ne réponds pas des parfois
certains confrères que c'est la langue
de bois chez lui c'est l'un des box que
je veux pas répondre à votre question
c'est vrai ça ça m'arrive mais je ne
mens pas je m'en bas parce que c'est
encore sonde il ya une expression qui
est pas mal qui dit abou jihad chambre
d'ailleurs le mensonge est boiteux et on
le voit de loin ça apporte le discrédit
et le discrédit sur une personne ça n'a
pas d'importance sur moi mais le
discrédit sur un mouvement politique
c'est grave je crois alors je ne crois
pas qu'on puisse me prendre un des fours
de ce point de vue là j'essaie de dire
pareil à tout le monde
jean guy talamoni solution